the left mourns the loss of a magazine
like the loss of a friend we had so much
quality time together you understood me
like no other well the motivation to
save these outlets is both political and
cultural because if one magazine or
publication newspaper is allowed to die
off the rest may follow along with their
influence enter Time magazine now
bleeding circulation for years and
unable to translate its print appeal
into the Internet age time has gone from
a circulation check this out of nearly
20 million worldwide to just a few
million primarily web-based folks the
only really thing keeping it going is
its to flagships the Person of the Year
issue comes out in December and it's 100
most influential issue the latter by the
way was released with PR today worthy of
a queen state visit the magazine created
a special series of covers for the issue
ten time Grammy winner Taylor Swift
two-time Golden Globe winner Sondra oh
and the House Speaker Nancy Pelosi our
cover stars
our very own Gayle King was also chosen
to grace a cover
now that's one surefire way of getting a
magazine featured on CBS Morning News
pick one of the anchors we like Gail by
the way aside from the obvious
influential folks Barr Muller and Trump
time included a few other curious
choices like Kavanagh accuser Christine
blase Ford about her guest profiler
Kamala Harris wrote her story spoken
while holding back tears shook
Washington and the country through her
courage she forced the country to reckon
with an issue that has too often been
ignored and kept in the dark totally
political what blase Ford did and said
last October was to accuse a man of
sexual misconduct 30 years prior with
zero corroboration I remember she
initially
an anonymous note accusing Kavanaugh
which was then leaked to The Washington
Post most importantly this icon at least
according to time failed to derail the
nomination so exactly how was that so
influential well as for Taylor Taylor
Swift I mean she continues to be an
entertainment juggernaut incredibly
talented but her big move this past year
was to throw in with the Democrats and
endorsed Marsha Blackburn Senate
opponent in Tennessee
well Blackburn decided to shake her off
and she won not so Swift perhaps to
think your pop music translates into any
great political appeal again rather than
be introspective about its loss of
appeal in middle America and beyond
Time magazine just keeps clinging to the
old liberal model of journalism and of
course clings to political correctness
we have 48 women on the list this year
up from 45 last year when we first
started doing this in 2004 I just went
back and counter there were 24 you know
obviously still ways to go in our
society the list is in some ways a
reflection of of our society the list is
not a reflection of our society the rest
of society doesn't throw itself a
glamorous party by the way like time
does when it's losing money by the
moment well speaking of glamorous model
and wife of John Legend Chrissy Teigen
was also chosen as one of the hundred
most influential now she's also known
for her vicious attacks on president
Trump and she was chosen according to
the profile because quote all her life
Chrissy Teigen has liked to eat she's
not shy about that or anything else
really well that's nice and innovative I
guess eating but did most Americans like
her take on female empowerment during
last week's Democrat retreat I think
it's possible to be really angry all the
time
if there was one word you would help
protect
women use more frequently but without
one word be oh okay the big shock that
joining the Trump hating model on the
list is a trump hating comedian Trump
hating filmmaker and a trump hating TV
producer well and for good measure they
threw in Michelle Obama Time magazine is
sort of the last gasp Almanac of the
elite but at least the elites don't
admit defeat easily do that you got to
hand that to them there's perhaps no
better example than how they've dealt
with Muller's no collusion and no
obstruction findings there's ample
evidence of collusion in plain sight
what we're talking about here is the
difference between conduct that rises to
the level of criminality and conduct
that is deeply unethical unpatriotic and
corrupt that may not be criminal the
Attorney General should recuse himself
immediately he has no business touching
any part of this investigation
okay well tomorrow's releasing the
Muller report - redactions we're bound
to see more gyrations from the same
suspects and from political activists
who raised millions off the constant
defamation that Trump was some type of
sellout to Russia or a traitor they've
moved by the way from he conspired with
the Russians to bar is just Reed acting
stuff to I don't know help Trump there
is absolutely no reason that there
should be redactions for the report as
provided to Congress our first priority
is getting the fully unredacted report
because the counterintelligence findings
may not even be covered in that report I
think it leaves a very strong impression
on the American people that this is a
form of political editing that is taking
place well and tonight they're grasping
at something new
the timing of Bill bars press conference
is this
conference a wafer bar to get out ahead
of any information that we might find in
the report and put his spin on it if you
want the public to take this report
seriously and to believe that the
Justice Department is credible you would
probably think twice about putting the
head of the Justice Department out on TV
to do spin for you he becomes the first
cabinet secretary to plunge into the
deep end of trumps conspiracy pool well
speaking of deep end we've gone from
trumps guilty of sedition to the AG is
guilty of aggressive scheduling one of
it is wait for the report to come out
read it and then gripe ok decide if you
have issues with it at that point if
this is the freak out happening tonight
I shouldn't even think about what's
gonna happen tomorrow we're gonna have a
great show on town and in the end the
Muller team well they spun their wheels
in the process what they ended up doing
is throwing a lot of mud at good people
sure there were indictments and guilty
pleas but between Ag bar and Inspector
General Michael Horowitz we may just
find out that the supposed guilty ones
were just deep state pawns the Muller
probe should have never been started in
the first place we told you that they
would find nothing on the president and
that its origins were politically
tainted and we were right and the left
was wrong even an op-ed in the
Washington Post admitting this Fox News
was right and the others were wrong even
regular viewers of CNN and MSNBC must
certainly recognize the straws being
grasped to justify sticking with a
conspiracy theory that has been largely
debunked well of course the hardcore
socialists and their media
co-conspirators will cling to the
Russian delusion for as long as they can
or simply shift to new targets within
Trump world there's such anti Trump
fanatics that they can't see that
they're committing unknowing self
sabotage to themselves personally and to
their party and to their movement like
their creaky best of lists their time is
finally long since up and that's the
angle